do you perform brisses or does that a
special that's a special skill right no
that's a special skill oh okay okay are
you asking for a reason yeah yeah
my favorite joke when I met at bris is
to say uh
it's to say man this calamari is good at
the dinner afterwards and then have
someone say there's no calamari and I go
oh
come on it's hilarious because it means
I accidentally ate the foreskin it's a
hilarious joke boy this calamari's
killer there's no calamari
try it out sometime Rabbi it's really
funny I will go to a TGI Fridays and go
boy this foreskin's delicious
I accidentally ate calamari
you know this is the stupidest thing
ever no after my son my first son was
born you know the custom in Judaism is
the foreskin has to be buried right you
can't dispose of it in any other way so
the the Moyle who did the brisk for my
son
gave it to me and I was like what am I
supposed to do with this I was a
rabbinical student living on the upper
west side and he said you have to bury
it but I lived in New York City yeah so
my friend and I went to Central Park and
we went behind home plate because huge
baseball fan and we buried it behind the
first field in Central Park
and now there's a foreskin tree growing
right there
every October dropping foreskins
do you have a question for Conan yes do
you have a question for me Rabbi how can
I counsel you oh yes so let's just say
you are the senior Rabbi Conan and Sona
and Matt are the associate rabbis what
would a clergy team meeting look like
well first of all I'd be there and I
think uh Rabbi Matt would be there as
well Sona would not be there because
she'd be running late and not caring oh
okay I think that you would be eating up
everyone's time by playing the guitar
for about an hour right but playing
holding up the meeting but playing songs
about Israel and uh playing songs about
Moses clergy like it does it doesn't it
doesn't cross anything off the agenda of
the meeting I would sing the dreidel
song I'm sending my rabbinical resume
over to you David to see if I can get a
transfer of some kind oh no you can't oh
no
um I gotta work under this guy because
you're the guy that I bring with me to
the bris whose job is to say we don't we
didn't serve any calamari
because I need someone to say that from
my joke to work for like a hundredth
times it's the 100th time
and I go but sometimes you don't do it
because you're so sick of it so I have a
little broomstick and I tap you with it
what if they are actually serving
calamari I know it's a drag that's a
problem then it's Matt's job to make
sure that they take the calamari out
okay and get rid of it his job is to get
there early and get rid of all the
calamari that they routinely serve at a
breast so is our meeting just discussing
how we're going to support your bids yes
yeah that would be yes here's what you
need to know David all of the meetings
would be okay I've got this bit I want
to do and here's what here's what I need
I need you to ask me I need you to say
this Matt and then when Sona shows up I
need you to do this and yeah so it would
be a lot of that I'm gonna do our son's
brisk correct no
we've got other people for that
no one calls you anymore for anything
yeah you're the only Rabbi no one calls
for anything
your workload would double David because
everybody from my yeah everybody who
worked at my temple would be like no no
no we're good Conan you'd be getting
twice as many calls lonely Rabbi at the
top of the hill that no one calls you
hear someone in your in your synagogues
having like marital trouble and you go
to them asking if you can help and
they're they're like no we're good yeah
we're good we're fine I heard you just
lost a parrot I'm fine it was good it
was good Conan O'Brien is Rabbi Without
a Cause
that's me in a red jacket color flipped
up James Dean Style
no one comes to talk to me
you know David you don't seem nervous at
all anymore you got over that really
quickly when you realized you were
talking too it's just amazing how our
clergy meetings are so similar to what
we're just doing that's good that's good
yeah yeah really
no no well yeah homes and yo-yo comes up
there's a lot of calamari jokes
sometimes I can be so naive